[Music]
in all show no tell news hotel-motel
that's what part of that mm-hmm Motel
bands yeah that's a week's when you take
her friend
oh that's J I'm up men I know that for
salt you know the one sure you're
hugging well a lot of people the
originals actually 15 minutes yeah yeah
you know that they repeat the same thing
it's like I mean that's a cool that's
like that song American Pie or whatever
I'm like [ __ ] this song gonna turn this
one's literally 15 minutes dude that
one's like that one's like the tenth
tall days of Christmas forever I'm like
damn dude and like this is the day the
music died and then he was like we went
to the levee and [ __ ] and then it keeps
on going on my damn bro I just know that
they like they didn't have them in New
Orleans or some [ __ ] like during that
Katrina that's all I know Bologna was
dry is that canals yeah they're like a
water thing it's not it's in the car
that's why I come to JK news we don't
need to know what the [ __ ] levee is
wrong those things exists here no one
will tell us I'd learned the Darth Vader
one first the Disney parody they're like
hey mr. anakin god
oh maybe Vader someday later now he's
just a small
yeah and then I learned the original
weird out though my back that's like
with the Christmas song with the Batman
and Robin eggs yeah that's the only
version they know that song you're all
the regular jingle bells song no I don't
I'm kidding this is submitted by Mexican
Super Mario okay he already looks
Mexican to me tell you Mexicans similar
clothes tomorrow
it's cuz probably your plumbers Mexicans
oh yeah [ __ ] on anything song and
it's like the foods that say mom my
uncle no I'm just gonna give it dude I
have no idea what's going on and I'm not
about to find out
that's why we're here what's going on
here tip oh here it is boys and girls
they study claims that men with beards
and great hair have the smallest
testicles oh I have half of a smallest
testing that's why your balls are big
but I don't have beards I poor hair you
have no beard and no hair chinstrap but
not a beard well yeah
is that not considered it's not box are
you it is for you it's a [ __ ] Sam oh
really yeah
I shave every [ __ ] day you're always
such a little baby doll you could get a
beard yeah I got beard beard where you
could like put beard oil in it well you
look like a patchy that's not beard [ __ ]
I just shave this morning [ __ ] I just
share this morning that's that's not a
bit of beard as a fool like the Dame
answer 11 your kid is like I got pubes
and you got one trying to justify your
small balls that's true
alright so researchers from the
University of Western Australia and the
University of zerk have found that male
primates can either be well adorned or
well endowed but not both hmm what's the
weight from down I'm not endowed with
dick size not ball size they're talking
about both like testicle like yeah it's
the whole package I think the whole
package is with small balls and vice
versa yeah you met them all honey if
they have elephantitis then that means
they got little ass dicks with big-ass
balls but does that mean they have a
long hair so they're saying to maximize
your chances of passing on their genes
males of many primate species invest
heavily in various sexual traits such as
a large body size or long canines that
can serve as weapons and direct concepts
over we're talk about monkeys here no no
they looked at over a hundred primate
species including human the females
subconsciously are like that guys canine
they shouldn't call us primates Oh cause
like we're way certain that I got canine
well there you go
so that means I got small balls cuz then
the more canines and hair you have the
less balls you got so they're saying
that shall we
sexual ornaments such as Mane's beards
fleshy swellings and colorful skin
patches can help them intimidate over
full skin patches wait animals and woo
female a beard is a sex sexual thing is
acne a colorful skin pitch yeah what is
it colorful skin the bruise is like the
blue ass for the boots are hilarious
or is he said that there in humans too
so I love it they're so proud of their
big blue butts I know would be too well
I mean it's not that different from
humans you know there's a lot of nice
butts on women that they're proud of
that's how the true we're really cold
we're really close to you know yeah so
they're saying that if Mel's can't
if males can't keep other males off of
their females they will try to
out-compete them at the level of sperm
and then they swap the sperm of others
so that they can increase their chances
of fertilization work and to produce a
lot of sperm a require large testicles I
heard about that we're like let's say
improvement of humans right like like if
they would just like gang Buster girl
then like that means like a lot of like
it comes out a lot of comes our having
okay so so the man with the most calm
winds how does that work have you seen
multiple cream pie porn cuz I bet you
that should happen that probably
happened back in a day insider but
scream that's why America has to dribble
out lied to you no no they bust incited
it oozes out yeah and then it news is
out Nikki obviously never [ __ ] watch
completed one watch I'm sure that they
did that in the past and in the
strongest sperm one or the most sperm
one cuz you [ __ ] bust a hot like like
a huge load right and then it's like
kind of washes out the rest of them like
you're busting courts and course yeah
depending yeah if it's a Wednesday let
me tell you the truth something about
where the moon is too depends how much
it mastery in between how far do you are
to I don't know about the science let me
tell you this I would tell you something
I don't come that much anymore right
it's alright I'm shooting blanks man
this is a brave man if you watch a lot
of porn I don't know he's posing for
don't don't know the science behind it
but I've been wondering yeah
because um so like when I don't know if
it's age or diet or whatever right
like I will bust like loads right but
then like these days it's like it's a
drip ball maybe a sugar because you stop
eating sugar oh so you still masturbate
or you're still coming but this is yeah
there's just but it's not like intense
like but you feel the calm but it's not
necessarily coming out that much oh it's
like this it's like so you know when you
do the like like that right it's my
favorite part let's say so that the
pumps right so like when you're shooting
the [ __ ] well when that happens like
let's say like it would you would pump
ten times or some [ __ ] right but then
now it's like look I'm done oh yeah
and then like the the amount the the the
load is less is it does it change of the
opaqueness because sometimes it's like
more white I don't inspect my nut you
don't I'll tell you just though when I
perfuse Lee used to masturbate this is
what would happen you yeah when I used
to [ __ ] come on a frequent basis he's
profusely ever used other than with
masturbation what if you're into this
experiment what happened okay so in
college this is a common thing it's not
it's not abnormal you masturbate very
frequently because studying makes you
want to masturbate that's true right and
then you just jack off so much to the
point where your dick is sore and even
though you don't even want to come no
more you do it again and then nothing
really comes out but this clear liquid
someday they're gonna build a statue of
you and they're gonna write all that
[ __ ] up and they should and they should
and everyone out there in internet land
knows exactly what I'm talking about
question for you yes what's the most
amount of times that you've came today
30 SEC's of masturbation five you don't
get sore I did yeah and then I started
like it would like the soreness care
would carry over and then I was like I
gotta stop yeah it was like in high
school for sure you can't count
hmm you kept count yeah because I
thought it was you know I was like yeah
I was kind of like is this too much you
know they're all different like
intensities
yeah cuz like they'll be like a little
baby when I'm like I count that two
nights ago I came in my seat like I was
waking up like I but I remember what I
was dreaming about it wasn't sexual it's
never a sexual dream when the Shepherd
so I heard about french fries they were
doing experiments on me like it was like
a sound experiment where I had to like
hear different sounds and stuff and and
but they left me alone in the room and I
was like I kind of turned on by this and
in my dream I went to go like touch
myself and I woke up orgasming but I
wasn't even touching myself I was like
totally like asleep like big like the 7d
what was the one wearing so [ __ ] the
movie where you didn't jerk off from a
spring he's just like oh wow were on the
girl and like she came just for that
those movies the Train guys wrong I
don't even have wet dreams but two days
ago I pissed my pants in bed that's not
it's not the same yeah I knew a guy who
jerked off 18 times every no in one day
this is like me no I know guy to who
used to fingers but all why he jerked
off I bet you was in Japan no he was
like 17 or 18 and it was on a school day
he's like guys I'm going to see how many
times I get jerk-off so he was like
going to the bathroom at school in
between periods and [ __ ] and get this
this is only five periods yeah I mean
that's a lot of dirt school a long time
that's what that's the day that I did it
that many times was during school - how
did he have a spank bank
I would just was he thinking about the
girls in class I'm so I can't wait to
send my kids to public school it's like
impossible he said after the sixth time
he started using the the rolling
technique which is like firestarter
that's not real he went like this you
can feel it you can feel it he's like I
just like I need to do this just for an
experiment for himself to know how much
he could come out did he start from the
morning at least
he's gonna give himself the best chance
like start at 6 a.m. yeah start early
finish late see his problem is he jacked
off too hard he was hard you got us you
gotta start it's off you got a paint
yourself or your little hot rod Tucker
dude and well did somebody die from like
seeing how many times yeah I think it
was like some crazy ass number and the
family told everyone that's what this is
a story to scare guys from mastery he
bitter died smilin actually forty six
forty two forty what they counted the
loads is [ __ ] for the numbers I know
cuz there's no way they found out
evidence what did he do never turn
already six times in a row nopes counted
the loads they say I was 38 if you have
a heart problem that's the only way
you're not allowed to orgasm do doctors
do warn you about that should they do
you ought to orgasm unless you couldn't
run up a flight of stairs and yeah
doctors warned you about sexual activity
if they think you have heart issues
yeah cuz if you get if you had a heart I
know someone that died during sex yeah
in high school yeah my friend and his
girlfriend at the time bags uh yeah they
she gave her half of a pill and they had
sex and then she died in the middle of
sex in a dead body
I don't know but couple weeks later we
were eating Chinese food and he was
crying over his orange chicken obviously
he was like suppressing it and like
blaming the right no I had nothing to do
the girl that was chicken was garbage
yeah I have a friend who his name is Joe
and he told me about how he used to date
this girl but she was too horny she was
too like she was too hard yes that's
awesome
and he's like no no no way too horny too
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]